-Here with the TV debut
of their new song, "Body Paint,"
from their upcoming album,
"The Car,"
give it up for Arctic Monkeys!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ For a master of
deception and subterfuge ♪
♪ You've made yourself
quite the bed to lie in ♪
♪♪
♪ Do your time traveling
through the tanning booth ♪
♪ So you don't let the sun
catch you crying ♪
♪♪
♪ So predictable ♪
♪ I know what you're thinking ♪
♪♪
♪ My teeth are beating,
and my knees are weak ♪
♪ It's as if there's
something up ♪
♪ With the wiring ♪
♪♪
♪ You can poke your head
behind the mountain peak ♪
♪ It don't have to mean ♪
♪ That you've gone into hiding ♪
♪♪
♪ So predictable ♪
♪ I know what you're thinking ♪
♪♪
♪ I'm watching your every move ♪
♪ I feel the tears
are coming on ♪
♪♪
♪ It won't be long ♪
♪ It won't be l-o-o-ong ♪
♪♪
♪ Straight from
the cover shoot ♪
♪ There's still a trace
of body paint ♪
♪ On your legs
and on your arms ♪
♪ And on your face ♪
♪ And I'm keeping on
my costume ♪
-♪ Keepin' on ♪
-♪ And calling it
a writing tool ♪
♪ And if you're thinking of me ♪
♪ I'm probably thinking of you ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ There's still a trace
of body paint ♪
♪ On your legs
and on your arms ♪
♪ And on your face ♪
♪ There's still a trace
of body paint ♪
♪ On your legs
and on your arms ♪
♪ And on your face ♪
♪ There's still a trace
of body paint ♪
♪ On your legs
and on your arms ♪
♪ And on your face ♪
♪ There's still a trace
of body paint ♪
♪ On your legs
and on your arms ♪
♪ And on your face ♪
♪♪
♪ So predictable ♪
♪ I know what you're thinking ♪
♪♪
♪ Ooh, ooh ooh ooh ♪
♪ Hah ♪
♪ Yeah ♪
♪ Ye-a-a-ah ♪
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]